now today is one of my favorite days is
pop quiz
i love these okay during our final
segment we're gonna ask one audience
member three questions about today's
show uh-huh so if you answer all three
correctly you win a thousand dollars
and
it's a hundred dollars for any that you
do get right so i think win win and
we'll play along see you at the end of
the show pay attention here we go it's
time for our pop quiz
all right
nicole hinkle
you've been selected
[Applause]
hi
oh that was so fun you didn't know
i love that
hi nicole how are you oh my god sorry i
love you
thank you thank you thank you no
were you paying attention to the show
all day yes very much so did you blink
even once
maybe just once okay
well we're gonna quiz you on what
happened today okay okay
okay
nicole if you correctly answer three
questions about today's show you'll win
one thousand
[Applause]
dollars and a hundred for every question
answered right so even if you get one
get something all right first question
how old was donny osmond when he made
his tv debut at just five years old
donnie made his tv debut on the andy
williams show five
oh that's right
one hundred dollars okay
question number two in the polenta that
you made with danny sayo did she use
fresh or frozen broccoli oh and they're
they're frozen they're frozen on purpose
so this is something where you don't
need fresh broccoli frozen broccoli is
actually just as fresh all the nutrients
are locked in and what it does it helps
to keep its shape
and it's
beautiful frozen
[Applause]
okay final question according to the
atlantic what does one couple schedule
with one another there's one married
couple from new jersey who's been doing
it for 40 years now but how
by scheduling their fights the atlantic
reports liz cutler and tom cruise swear
by the system they schedule a
disagreement meeting once every three
months
[Applause]
a fights dollars but wait
wait you have a thousand dollars there
in your hand but we have a twist drew
well you can walk away with your one
thousand dollars today or you can give
it back to us right now and you can come
back tomorrow to play a super sized pop
quiz for the chance to win
five thousand dollars
i will come back tomorrow
[Applause]
this is just so exciting we're finally
seeing the potential of pop quiz god i
love how
i am so excited it's like you know
reaching the top of everest you're just
like i'm gonna get we're gonna get there
one day and here we are pull it together
barrymore all right never you took a
risk you gave back the one thousand
dollars so tomorrow we're gonna see you
for the chance to win 5k
[Applause]
[Music]